the realm
do you know what the realm is
[Music]
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another house of the dragon
video
well it's official my friends hbo has
released their first images from their
upcoming series house of the dragon
hbo has now confirmed that production
will begin
after the new year and as of right now
house of the dragon is still on schedule
for a 2022 release date
as you can see they have also shared a
first look at some of the official
artwork from the game of thrones
spin-off show
this new artwork shows one of the
dragons that will be featured
in house of the dragon they haven't
officially given a name for this dragon
but many fans are already speculating on
which one it could be some fans say that
it could be karaxis
or syrax while others say it could even
be sunfire
either way this will only be the first
of many dragons we will see
in the new show now i will say this
artwork is basically only a rough draft
for what the dragon may look like but
chances are
it will be slightly different once it's
rendered for the screen
so just keep that in mind for now this
is exciting though because now we're
finally starting to see
glimpses of the show coming alive now
there has also been some new casting
updates as well
this has not been confirmed by hbo
themselves but there are rumors that hbo
is considering hiring matt smith as
daemon targaryen
some of you may already know matt smith
from the crown
or even doctor who since hbo has already
filled the shoes of viserys targaryen
it would make sense if they filled the
role for his brother daemon next
like i said this is not official as of
right now but hopefully some more
announcements will be released in the
following days
the original game of thrones series was
mostly shot in northern ireland
but it's looking like house of the
dragon will set up their base of
operations at the leavesden studios in
england
if you happen to live in that area keep
your eyes open because filming will most
likely begin
and only a few months from now if you
happen to get any photos of the actors
while they're in the area or especially
if they're on set
feel free to drop them in my email that
would be great
as of right now i want to keep this
video short and sweet
at least until some more details are
released
let me know if you're excited for house
of the dragon i know i
certainly am westeros will be on fire
once again because
the dragons are coming fire will
reign
[Music]
you